hace tiempo que ya decidimos la suma de
dos vectores y la multiplicación por
escalar en este vídeo quiero ver otras
operaciones con vectores pero no sin
antes recordar cuáles son las
operaciones que ya habíamos visto de dos
vectores la primera era la suma o la
resta de un vector con otro así que
vamos a tomarnos un vector a 1 a 2 hasta
a n y vamos a tomarnos el siguiente
vector b1 b2 hasta bn y vamos a sumarlos
ellos 2 y bueno el resultado de la suma
de dos vectores me daba un vector con en
entradas también y en cada una de sus
componentes o en cada una de sus
entradas tomábamos la suma de las dos
componentes correspondientes de los
vectores iniciales las sumas la veíamos
como a uno más b uno en la primera
componente a dos más b dos en la segunda
componente y así hasta n b n en la n va
componente y bueno ahora voy a pensar
qué pasaba cuando nosotros multiplicamos
por escalar la multiplicación por
escalar o podríamos decir que es una
multiplicación escalada esta era otra de
las operaciones que ya habíamos definido
la cual era muy útil cuando nosotros
hablábamos de vector
y decía que si nosotros teníamos una
constante que multiplicaba un vector de
entradas una constante que multiplica el
vector a 1 a 2 hasta a n el resultado de
esta operación era multiplicar la
constante por cada una de las
componentes de este vector es decir
tenemos c1 por a1 esto es la primera
entrada en la segunda entrada era hace 2
a 2 en la tercera entrada hace 3 a 3
días y hasta cnn y recuerda que habíamos
dicho que la multiplicación por escalar
lo que hacía era que la longitud del
vector y bueno yo sé que no he definido
la longitud de un vector sin embargo
esta longitud del vector de hacíamos
crecer cuántas veces nos dijera el
escalar recuerda que dé resultado
obtendríamos un vector con lineal pero
este vector se sea grande o pequeño
según lo que nos decía al escalar pero
bueno este es un vídeo importante porque
en este vídeo quiero hablarles acerca de
la multiplicación de matrices pero es
que realmente hay varias formas de
definir una multiplicación de matrices
por eso la primera multiplicación de
matrices que vamos a ver es el producto
punto el producto punto y es que date
cuenta que como la definición de matriz
es bastante amplia entonces
podemos definir varios tipos de
multiplicación fíjate bien aquí tengo a
punto b y si hay una cruz en medio de la
clave no es la misma operación para que
sea producto punto en medio de los dos
vectores debe de tener un punto a punto
b
tengo dos vectores y como define la
operación producto punto pues vamos a
ver quién es el vector a supongamos que
el vector a es igual que el que está acá
arriba es a uno a dos hasta a n es un
vector con entradas punto de el vector
de voy a suponer que es el vector desde
acá arriba b1 b2 hasta bn con en
entradas y como defino a punto ven bueno
a punto b es la operación de dos
vectores la cual me da de resultado lo
siguiente a uno por b uno más a dos por
de dos es decir voy a multiplicar las
correspondientes entradas a 3 por b 3 y
las voy a sumar todas más a 4 por b 4
más trata más a n por b n es decir cada
una de las correspondientes entradas las
voy a multiplicar y voy a tomarme la
suma de todas ellas
cuenta me da de resultado algo que no es
un vector me da un escalar de resultado
al final esto va a ser un número que
existen los reales porque estamos
multiplicando y sumando por los números
reales así que yo sé que esto está muy
abstracto y mejor vamos a verlo con un
ejemplo me voy a tomar el vector 25 ya
éste le voy a calcular el producto punto
con el vector 71 y bueno usando la
definición estos dos por siete más cinco
por uno solo acabo de aplicar lo que
vimos aquí abajo y esto es 14 + 6 no no
esperen esperen 5 hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque estos errores son
mortales y bueno 14 más 5 19 y date
cuenta que 19 es un número real y por lo
tanto no obtengo de resultado un vector
obtengo un escalar ahora voy a tomar el
producto punto de otros dos vectores
para que sigamos practicando esta idea
del producto punto me voy a tomar el
vector en r 3 1 2 3 ya este le voy a
calcular su producto punto con el vector
menos 20 5 y de resultado me va a quedar
1 x menos 2 más 2 x 0
3 x 5 multiplicamos y luego sumamos y me
va a quedar menos 20 más quince y esto
me da 13 entonces 13 es un número
escalar y aquí ya hay un segundo ejemplo
de lo que me refiero con producto punto
pero bueno es hora de definir otra
propiedad hablando de vectores voy a
definir en este momento a qué me refiero
con la longitud de un vector la longitud
del vector podríamos decir que es cuánto
mide este vector desde el punto inicial
hasta el punto final y me vas a decir
oye pero por qué me tengo que esperar
hasta un curso universitario para saber
lo que es la longitud yo ya sé lo que es
la longitud no sé en r2 o en r3 por qué
me estás definiendo ahorita la longitud
de un vector oye sal pero esto ya me lo
sé saco una regla y entonces lo mido y
se acabó sin embargo es que esta
definición es una definición formal y
además es una definición general es
decir que si yo quisiera medir un vector
en r 50 es decir en 50 dimensiones y
quisiera saber la longitud de este
vector pues entonces con esta fórmula ya
sé la longitud de un vector
en 50 dimensiones la longitud de un
vector que por cierto se denota con el
vector encerrado entre cuatro líneas
como si fuera un valor absoluto doble es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de tomarme la
primera componente y elevarlo al
cuadrado ya esto sumarle la segunda
componente y elevarlo al cuadrado ya
esto sumar la tercera componente y
elevar de cuadrado y así hasta llegar a
la nba componente y también elevarla al
cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de todo esto y
esto es lo que se define en longitud de
un vector y vuelvo a decirte es una
definición completamente general por
ejemplo en el caso de que éste fuera el
vector de quién sería la longitud de
este vector
bueno pues de longitud de este vector
sería la primera componente elevada al
cuadrado más la segunda componente
elevada al cuadrado y eso es lo mismo
que la raíz cuadrada de 4 más 25 4 más
25 es 29 por lo tanto la longitud de
este vector d sería la raíz cuadrada de
29 y es que todo esto sale del teorema
de pitágoras del famoso teorema de
pitágoras que vemos entre econometría
fíjate bien supongamos que aquí tengo
mis dos ejes coordenadas y que voy a
dibujar a este vector aquí
tengo dos a la derecha uno dos tres
cuatro cinco hacia arriba entonces por
lo tanto aquí tengo mi vector ven este
es mi vector de y si yo quise saber la
longitud de este vector pues es lo mismo
que dibujar un triángulo por acá fíjate
aquí tengo que subir cinco hacia arriba
y tengo dos hacia la derecha y obtengo
este triángulo que estoy dibujando aquí
este es uno de mis catetos
este sería mi otro de mis catetos cada
una de las componentes de mis catetos y
como es un triángulo rectángulo la
hipotenusa es igual a la raíz cuadrada
del primer cateto al cuadrado más el
segundo cateto al cuadrado es el teorema
de pitágoras pero bueno esto ya lo sabes
porque estamos hablando de r2 pero si
hablamos de un vector de 10 dimensiones
entonces la longitud del vector está
definida con esta expresión que yo tengo
aquí abajo la raíz cuadrada la primera
componente elevada al cuadrado más la
segunda componente elevada al cuadrado
más todas las componentes elevadas al
cuadrado
ahora quiero regresar un poquito a
hablarles del producto punto porque yo
tengo una pregunta por aquí
qué pasa si calculamos el producto punto
de un vector consigo mismo es decir
supongamos que tomamos el vector amp y
le vamos a calcular el producto punto
consigo mismo
a punto a bueno vamos a ver por la
definición de producto punto aquí
tenemos el vector a punto el vector am y
entonces si escribo a los dos vectores
aquí me va a quedar el primer vector que
este es el vector am punto el vector am
es decir a1 a2 hasta en y esto era ni
más ni menos que la primera componente
por la primer componente del otro es
decir a un elevado al cuadrado más la
segunda componente por la segunda
componente del otro que en este caso
como es el mismo vector es a 2 elevado
al cuadrado más la tercer componente por
la tercer componente y así hasta llegar
a la nba componente que multiplica a la
nueva componente y por lo tanto me va a
quedar en elevada al cuadrado y si te
das cuenta esto se parece mucho lo que
está dentro de la raíz cuadrada que
teníamos en la longitud de un vector o
podríamos decir la longitud de un vector
no podemos escribir como la raíz
cuadrada de a punto del vector a que le
calculamos el producto punto consigo
mismo o dicho de otra manera de una
manera mucho más elegante podemos decir
que la longitud de un vector elevado al
cuadrado es exactamente lo mismo que si
a ese mismo
y calculamos el producto punto consigo
mismo y bueno es que esta expresión de
aquí fue fácil probarla pero no va a ser
muy útil para los siguientes vídeos que
vamos a ver y además en los siguientes
vídeos lo que quiero ver son más
propiedades acerca de la longitud y del
producto punto y estas propiedades tal
vez sean un poco sencillas de demostrar
pero nos van a servir bastante nuestras
demostraciones futuras